mal et tout d'abord la politique avec
les réactions après les propos du
commandant cousteau les mouvements
écologistes sont une fois de plus
divisée le commandant cousteau dans le
journal de 20 heures d'antenne 2 a
déclaré que malgré les nombreuses
sollicitations
il ne serait pas candidat aux
présidentielles certains écologistes
s'en réjouissent sans trop le dire
d'autres le regrette notamment la
tendance de solange fernex qui
souhaitaient cette candidature d'union
mais tous sont satisfaits du soutien
actif que jacques-yves cousteau a promis
de leur apporter
écoutez ce qu'il a dit tout à l'heure
après avoir annoncé sa décision
alors cette décision entraîne quand même
un certain nombre de conséquences
ça ne veut pas dire que je me
désintéresse du mouvement écologique en
france au contraire
donc si vous voulez la grande leçon pour
moi de cette méditation c'est de me dire
peut-être que tu ne t'es pas assez
occupé de ton pays pendant ces dernières
années qui a voulu voler trop par
conséquent j'ai l'intention de m'occuper
plus des questions de mon pays à
l'avenir que je m'en suis occupé dans le
passé alors que renforcer cette action
française l'écologie en même temps
j'aiderai les mouvements écologiques aux
présidentielles justement voulons brandt
et pour qui vous allez voter henri télé
relève ne me demandez pas ça donne la
parole et aux écologistes ces domaines
qui désignent leur candidat et je
suivrai la discipline c'est à dire que
je soutiendrai leur clan des nerfs